Jar, my favorite guest. What's up, man?
>> Hello.
>> What's up, dog?
>> Oh, I think I remember listening to your
conversation with him last time.
>> Yeah.
>> I want to I want to talk about something
uh that you me
>> You want to talk about your conversion?
>> No, I'm still a Muslim. Alhamdulillah.
>> No, you shouldn't be. Not according to
your word.
>> No, no. Again, I had to do my research
and I went on Daw Wise's stream today,
talked about it and whatnot. Dawa. So
the the daise is full of morons.
>> No, they're not morons.
>> Jabber, you said you talked to them
about what we talked about.
>> Yeah. And they said uh two things.
Number one, uh we should look at the
eight criteria that Aristotle mentioned
about what a contradiction is. And the
second thing is they have response to
it. But let's first look at
>> what was their answer. What was the
response that fixed the problem?
>> Okay. So um it says so these letters
whatn not you know alim you said that's
what that's what you this what your
contention is where those letters mean
>> Abraham's wife Moses's wife Adam's wife
>> uh
>> no no no remember I I I I I I decided to
leave on the interpretation that's uh
that it's about uh you know that the
like you you yeah sorry you mentioned
that you mentioned that uh chapter 12
verse 111 it it goes goes against what
the chap uh for example chapter 2 verse
one says chapter 3 says yeah you said
that you said that last time you said
>> yeah that that that shows that those
verses are unexplained
>> those are examples of the Quran not
being explained
>> right right and then so then I asked
them today about that and they said oh
um it it it's those word those letters
you know and whatnot they connect to the
next verse and because uh it's like a
it's like a to show the Arabic uh the
Arabic's eloquence,
>> right?
>> No, it is because the eloquence of the
Arabic for example with some
prepositional words in Arabic
>> you know you know you know I love you
right man like a brother.
>> Yeah
>> I love you ma'am. So you know I won't
steal you wrong and because I love you I
tell you the truth nothing but the truth
and I tell you straight up.
>> Go ahead. I'm listening.
>> Stop listening to these idiots.
>> Nah nah nah.
>> Stop bro. Stop taking these silly uh
dumb erroneous explanations from these
people.
>> Mhm.
>> These ad hoc interpretations that can't
be proven from the text or the context
at all.
>> Mhm.
>> Stop taking from them, bro. This is
probably like what the the sixth one
we've gone over now.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> It's none of it doesn't work. And what
>> what this they brought the they brought
the other thing up for a contradiction.
You said uh the Quran has to have a
contradiction. And you said uh I I asked
him about that today and they said uh
look up the eight criteria that
Aristotle made to prove what a
contradiction is. How about we should go
over that to see what
>> Sure. No problem. What was their answer
though? But we we could do that and have
some fun there later. What was their
answer to the to the problem? Like you
know, let me ask you, did you ask them?
Hey guys, a Christian brought up this
verse to me. Chapter 12 vers 11.
>> Yeah, we can even replay the video. I
it's today.
>> Okay, I believe you. So you you showed
them the verse and you gave them my
argument. Hey, he's saying that there's
examples in the Quran of verses that are
not explained.
>> Yeah. And then they said those those
letters mean uh like basically those
letters connect to what comes after
>> connects to
this is talking about the Quran, you
know, and all
>> about what what is it saying about the
Quran? That's the question. What is it
saying about the Quran? Did they tell
you what? Now I I can because look, I
can say that verse two of Sarah Bakar
connects to verse three of Sarabakura.
But
>> they're saying verse one connects to
verse two, which
>> in verse one, I get you. Verse one
connects to verse two. But what does
verse one mean?
>> It doesn't have a meaning by itself. I'm
saying it has to be connected.
>> So it's not Okay, fine.
>> There are some words in Arabic that
could don't just that that just don't
have a meaning by itself.
>> These are words. Alf are words
>> by itself. You don't know what it means
but with with like if there's another
verse after it.
>> That's what it is by itself. And then
the verse. Okay. So the verse after
>> just take a verse by it.
>> Okay. Cool. You know let's do this.
Let's let's look at it. Let's look at it
and let's see if verse two combined with
verse one alam tells us what that means.
You with me?
>> Yeah I'm with you.
>> All right. So verse one alf lam.
>> Are you going to do chapter two?
>> Yeah I'm in chapter two.
>> Okay. Al of lamin. Matter of fact, let's
do this. Let me put it on the screen for
both of us to see.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I've got it memorized
already, but anyway.
>> Okay. Alfamine. It's funny. You see what
they put in the in the parenthesis?
These letters are one of the miracles of
the Quran.
>> It is. It is. You know how I can explain
how. I can explain how.
>> Look at what he says though.
>> Okay.
>> And none but Allah alone knows their
meanings. But you think dah wise know
their meaning? Man, you guys, they all
over the place. J. And then and then
here's the second interpretation I got
for for alle what it means.
>> Wait, not the second. Let's see the
let's see let's go the first one. Let's
see if verse two explains it. Okay. This
is a book where uh there is no doubt a
guidance to those who are uh the
>> right. Okay. Um I'm trying to skip the
Oh, that's it. Huh? Because this is just
the rest is just brackets.
>> Uhhuh. They they add a lot of brackets
to the Quran. It needs a lot of help in
explaining.
>> Yeah. Well, I'm sure chapter 12 verse
111 itself has brackets.
>> It doesn't actually.
>> You sure?
>> So, well, it depends on the translation
you use actually because you're actually
right. Depends on the translation.
>> A lot of brackets, man. Needs a lot of
help.
>> Needs a lot of help. All right. So, uh
yeah. So, this is the book about which
there is no doubt guidance for those
conscious of Allah. How does this tell
us what alam me is?
>> Okay. Okay. There's another
interpretation they brought about what
alam me is.
>> Wait, can can we scratch that? Can we
scratch that?
>> Okay, let us we scratch that. Okay.
>> All right. So, that one we get we say
that that one dumb, right?
>> Out the window. Out the window. Let's
go. Let's go to the second
interpretation where there's where this
one it comes from the miracle of Allah.
You know how you know? Let me explain.
Okay.
>> Go ahead. Go ahead.
>> Listen to me. So, let me give you an
example. Uh let me just find the chapter
number. Just a sec. I I believe it's
chapter 104. It says uh the chapter the
elephant, right? It says
Right? The first three letters used in
that verse is
okay. But we don't say
we just we say
okay while here in verse what verse
>> this is like chapter 104 I believe I I
could be wrong just a minute chapter
chapter the elephant uh
>> okay the elephant all right let me
>> the elephant okay if you read the Arabic
in the first verse the first three
letters in in that verse is al
Right.
>> What verse? Oh, you said verse one.
>> Verse one. Okay. So, it says,
right? Right.
>> Okay.
>> Right. Here um it is.
Here's the thing. Why don't we say in
why don't we say that? Because to show
that the Quran is preserved, we even
have the pronunciation preserved. So we
know when to use and when to use. So
Allah basically he put me to show us
that the Quran can actually be preserved
fully.
>> Did that convince you?
>> No.
>> Why not?
>> I I didn't I didn't hear an explanation
of what alf means.
>> No. No. I told you it's in the Quran
because Allah wants to show that the
Quran will be preserved fully in
pronunciation.
>> Where does the Where does the Quran say
that?
>> Chapter 15:9.
>> No. Where does the Quran say that the
meaning or reason for Alamim is to
demonstrate the preservation of the
Quran's linguistics?
>> Again, in chapter 15:9, it's how else
are we going to show that the Quran is
preserved? In chapter 15:9, it just says
that Allah sent down the reminder and
that he guards it.
>> It says nothing about Alf or the or the
purpose of it. You get what I'm saying?
>> Yeah.
>> So, does the Quran tell you what you
told me about why Alfam is there? Does
the Quran say that?
>> Does the Quran say that? Um, no. But we
can infer by it by by the just passed
down from generation to generation. Just
like da wise can infer that alf lamin is
there to connect is connected with the
other verse and somehow that shows the
meaning or they can infer that as well
or the other scholar that you was
bringing up can infer what they were
saying about alaflam meme and you
laughed at what they inferred and then
the other scholars that defer with that
and you you we laugh remember we was
laughing at all these different
interpretations of me.
>> Yeah. Um, so
>> but they're all they're all inferring
that
>> again. Um, um, also I'm going to say
>> thank you. That's the point. Allah alam
Allah knows best and he's the only one
who knows.
>> And what's the problem?
>> The problem is is that the verse says
the Quran is a detailed explanation of
everything
>> and everything.
>> If only Allah knows then the Quran is
not explained. But again uh uh maybe
scholars have to explain what the
detailed explanation is. Maybe scholars
will have to explain.
>> Yeah. Yeah. A scholar needs to come and
tell you and I jabber what it means to
be detailed and explain. We we're too
stupid to know what that means. You know
>> Yeah.
>> I'm not smart enough. You're not smart
enough. My friend IP here, he's not
smart enough.
>> What's his channel's name, by the way?
>> Huh?
>> Inspiring Philosophy. It's uh it's
tagged in the in the title of this
video.
>> What a coincidence that that there's
there's this guy in Dawis. His name is
uh Islam Hakeim. He has a channel cogent
faith. This guy is really philosophical,
you know. He talks everything Aristotle,
you know, uh I don't know Plato told him
to come here.
>> No, but he was busy like on the Dao
stream, you know.
>> Yeah. You should have said, "Hey, you
guys should go and give this explanation
to go logic. see what he responds.
>> I didn't want to say I was debating you
because like you know
>> they they they would have kicked you if
they told if they said that they
>> No, it's not that bad. No, they're just
gonna be give me a big scolding. You
know, why do you want to debate nobody's
blah blah blah? They're they're very
unnowledgeable and you know whatot you
know actually.
>> I have a question for you. No, no, no,
stop that. I have a question for you. I
have a question.
>> Wait.
>> Um my question is how can I question
>> how can I Sorry. Before your question,
we got to make sure.
>> Okay. How can I copy and paste how can I
copy and paste a link to the private
like I want to uh uh paste the YouTube
link here.
>> Maybe you can respond to it, but I found
it
>> here. I got you. I got you. So, what
I'll do
>> But how do you do it?
>> All you got to do You're on Are you on
your computer?
>> My phone.
>> You're on your phone. Okay. So, on your
phone, do you see the private chat?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. But see, how do I copy
and paste the link on there?
>> Oh, you're trying to paste the link in
my chat. Yeah, because uh there's a
video that I found that exactly talks
about this exact topic. I didn't really
like uh I didn't watch the whole thing,
but I just found
>> Don't past it here.
>> I mean, also this doesn't really solve
the contradiction because surah 1211
says it's a detailed explanation of all
things. But even if they could explain
the alf
whatever aspect, surah 37 still exists,
which says that some things are
included.
>> I responded to him about 3 37. I I I
I'll tell you the explanation that uh
that I I got from 37. Some scholars some
scholars they make a mistake and they
put a comma after nobody knows except
Allah. It should be saying nobody knows
except Allah and the people of
knowledge. That's how it's in the
Arabic. So if you go to the verse, it
says nobody knows the explanation but
Allah. Some people put like a period or
a comma next to it, but there shouldn't
be there. There shouldn't be one there.
It should be nobody knows.
>> Why is it?
>> No, no, no. It's it's That doesn't even
matter.
>> That doesn't even matter.
>> Go ahead, man. Yeah, you got it.
>> What what matters is is that that you
have a verse that says that the Quran is
perfectly detailed and explained.
>> So regardless of that verse, if there
are unexplained verses in the Quran,
that's a contradiction.
>> Mhm.
>> So even if I don't have a verse in the
Quran that also says, hey, there's
unclear verses, that doesn't solve the
problem that there are unclear verses
while the Quran says that everything is
explained and clear, detailed, you know.
So that's why 37 doesn't matter.
>> Yeah, 37. Yeah, we just, you know, we we
we left it by itself.
>> But anyway, yeah, look, the other thing
I wanted to do, they said to to look up
the eight criteria that Aristotle put
out for what a contradiction is,
>> but that doesn't none of that matters.
>> None of that matters because a
contradiction you cannot have a and be
non- A in the same way in the same
sense. So
>> remember all eight criteria have to be
>> brother
>> you we you both you and I understand you
cannot have a statement saying that the
book is a detailed explanation of
everything.
>> Can you hear me?
>> Oh sorry I I have to I have to uh
somebody's knocking on my door. Sorry
I'll be back.
>> All right.
Just just what I was trying to get at
while he's coming back is that if you go
to the life of Muhammad and Iak,
Muhammad does not give that explanation
of 37.
>> Oh, that's true.
>> No, he said the the Christians come and
they go, why is Allah constantly calling
himself we and are? And he goes, well,
that's a mystery. Uh, no one knows that
but Allah. And that that's his
explanation for that. So, even with the
Alflem stuff, the Muhammad said the
parts about Allah calling himself we are
unexplained. Yes. Al the same thing when
it comes to Jesus being Allah's word, a
spirit and a and a spirit from him. The
Christians were using that against him
and Muhammad used 37 as a as a response
that
>> uh these are verses that are unclear and
those who are deviant are trying to use
the unclear verses to stir up trouble
and and cause doubts.
>> So
>> yeah, and people of knowledge the comma
issue that's not what Muhammad said. So
I mean like this is just the miracle of
reinterpretation.
>> Yeah. The miracle of reinterpretation.